Ninety-seven percent of the varieties of vegetables...
...grown at the beginning of the 20th century are now extinct.
Genetic uniformity leads to an increased vulnerability to insects and disease.
Farmers found themselves trapped on a pesticide treadmill.
The more they sprayed, the more they had to spray.
The increased use of fertilizers, pesticides and herbicides...
...increased costs, polluted water and created health risks.
Then in the 1970s, Monsanto introduced Roundup.
Because of its ability to kill most weeds,...
...it became one of the most popular herbicides in history.
In the mid-1990s building on technologies that use gene splicing,...
...the Green Revolution turned into the Gene Revolution.
Capitalizing on the new technology,...
...Monsanto genetically modified its seeds to be Roundup ready.
Normally, Roundup kills anything green.
But if the plant is Roundup ready when it is sprayed, it doesn't die.